Speaker 1: Mike Pillow, also known as Mike
Lindell, the CEO and founder of Mypillow,
was in Des Moines, Iowa for Donald Trump's
canceled rally. This was the rally that
due to depending on who or what you believe,
either because of a tornado watch or because
of low attendance, depending on who you ask.
There's two conflicting views. Was canceled.
Mypillow Mike Lindell was there and he made an
incredible statement. He says he has blown. I'm
calling it blown. He has spent he has blown $40
million on all of this election nonsense. Now,
the last time I interviewed pillow or pillow,
as some call him, he told me he was at 35
million spent. As of that point in time.
Speaker 5: Doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines.
Speaker 1: Clearly,
the machine lawsuits have upped that to
40 million. Here he is explaining it.
Speaker 5: What we're doing with Briggs
speech within the next couple of weeks,
I could be for 2 to 4 weeks. We're offering a
stock to the public. This is going to be amazing.
We're offering stock to the public. I want
every person out there to have a little piece
of the pie for this country. I write with the
money that I use to save this country that I've
been outspending. I've spent over $40 million.
Speaker 3: Unbelievable. Hang on a second. He
spent over $40 million on nothing.
Speaker 1: On literally nothing.
Speaker 5: I've spent anyhow. And
I need help. You know we need help,
but we need help making the voice bigger. Yeah,
and we need help. The money. And you'll see this
when this happens. I can't tell the details, the
lawyer said. I will only later introduce my true.
Speaker 3: Yes.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Okay.
So pillow. I mean, listen, it's increasingly a
sad story. I believe pillow is a true believer.
He does seem to believe this stuff. And according
to various reports, he's wrecked his family life
with this election nonsense and he's spent
40 million bucks. I think he has like two or
300 million. So he's still going to be fine.
But that's a lot of money to waste. He then
during the same interview, if you can call it
that, says he put bed bath and B, excuse me,
bed bath. It's so ridiculous. I'm choking on my
own words. He says that he's responsible for Bed,
Bath and Beyond bankruptcy because they
stopped carrying his pillows or something.
Speaker 5: You know, they were afraid and fear
and and they I should know the real people are
going to get are not going to shout their if
you do this to me. Yeah, that's what happened.
That's exactly what happened. But, you know,
I feel bad that all those jobs were lost. He's
ones that are going bankrupt and stuff. We are.
Speaker 1: If only they had my pillow pillows
available, they would have been saved. That is
that is a cautionary tale. Okay. And then lastly,
this is now totally beyond parody. He pillow
claims he has new election crime evidence. He's
no longer calling it election fraud. He's now
calling it election crime. And he says that in
two weeks it's going to be released.
Speaker 3: Let's talk real quickly
about what you talked about, the crime
and when can when can we expect that?
Speaker 5: Okay. This is real important that you
can go to election Crime Bureau dot com. Right.
The Election Crime Bureau, I formed about, oh,
about a month and a half ago now. And within two
weeks, as we say, we're getting the other now.
Speaker 1: Okay. So in two weeks they're
going to be publishing that information. You
would think that by now his family would have
intervened. Except it seems as though the
relationship with his family is wrecked. So
they may have completely lost control of pillow.
A sad and cautionary tale. Okay. The conspiracies
can drive you closer to bankruptcy. It's not
just benign. When you believe in this stuff,
you could get drifted into donating to someone
like Pillow or Trump, or you could end up,
you know, skating off with for $4,040 million
and beat being. And in the situation Pillow
now finds himself. I don't expect any big
election crime bombshells in two weeks but
I've been wrong before just not about
this topic and I could be wrong again.